Okay.
Next time don't hit it that hard, but come on in, come on in.
All right.
So today we're going to do something pretty fun. Welcome to my place again.
And, uh, yeah, today I'm not the star of the show.
The star of the show today is Matt show my
cinematographer. So I'm going to be teaching him how to program.
So you guys ready? It's going to be pretty basic because how much,
how much do you know nothing? Are you sure? Yeah. Nothing at all. Nothing,
but you want to get to Stanford, right? Yes. Right.
Okay.
All right. 30 minutes session, because we can only record for 30 minutes.
All right. Let's start now. I'm going to, I'm going to read my notes,
but pretend you don't see my notes. Okay. Yeah.
So I guess the first question,
how much programming do you know? Or do you even know what is programming?
Programming is what makes phones?
Yeah. Oh, wait, you.
Can tell me about yourself a little bit for eight K how old you are. Oh, my 16,
like a good.
[Inaudible].
I mean, I'm an isolate aligner. Yeah. Well idea of Tim.
And then now I'm making videos with him, but that's about it. So yeah.
Matt is indeed 16 and he's probably the best photographer.
No, which is great because when you're 16, you're pretty cheap. So
not too expensive. Yeah. It keeps just doesn't pay anything. Yeah.
I just don't pay anything. Cause, cause he's, cause he's a, he's a fan boy,
but I, I see the, the investment, you know, potential, potential potential,
but yeah. It's okay.
Cause I'm going to sell video courses soon so we can use information, money,
better buy them so I can pay you. All right.
The reason why I'm doing this is because I want you to get into Stanford.
So you could be closer to where I live so we can make more videos.
Yeah. I don't care if you have like a successful career or not.
So I guess one thing that I want to talk about is that, uh,
when people think about programming, coding,
they think about just making websites and stuff like that, you know is cause,
um, cause whenever I hear about coding, they always say like, Oh,
the first thing you learn should be HTML and CSS. It's like, yes,
but first of all, those aren't even coding languages. Did you know that? No. No.
Actually I knew that. Oh, you knew that. Okay. Okay. So you know your. So yeah.
So you usually think about that, but it's actually not even coding.
The coding is basically the art of automation.
The whole point of coding is to what did I say?
Delegate tasks on machine rather than doing it yourself so they can do it
automatically. What else did I write? And how do you tell them to do things?
You give them very, very precise and those instructions is basically your code.
All right. So are you ready to learn some fundamentals? Okay.
First function we learn that is already made.
Like you're not going to write this function. It's called print. Okay.
For example, gentleman's dope. Okay.
And then what happens when you run this? You get gentleman's though. Right?
So this thing in between print is a string,
meaning it's words or like characters and you could also put numbers and then
this function is smart enough to print different things, you know? Okay, cool.
So try it yourself. Try to print, um, like, hi,
my name is.
Gotcha.
Yeah. So that's clearly wrong. I said match. Hope not. It's wonderful. Bulky.
You get the point. So let's learn about functions.
So let me tell you what functions does. So this is the syntax for functions.
Like this is how you write Def means you start a function.
You could write any name. Like, so I write dog.
These parenthesis I'll talk about later, but I'll just add them now.
And then I could print. Don't go. Right?
And then if I run this, what happens is that it runs the whole file.
So now if I run the file in means this has been recorded,
the function has been recorded. So if I run it,
it says doggle so let's do something funky.
What do you think would happen if I print?
And then I put dog there, what do you think that will happen?
It's going to print this whole thing. Like what do you mean?
What's it going to just get a print dog? It's actually going to print nothing.
Oh wait. Oh, it is going to get toggle. Sorry, my bad, but okay.
So the reason why doggle got printed is because we call this function,
but then why is there none? Like, for example, if I do dog, it prints toggle.
But then if I do print dog, it does nothing.
The reason is because this function returns nothing. Basically this is what,
what what's really happening is returning nothing. But you can return,
like for example, for, you know, print,
print is actually nothing related to what you're going to output in terms of
your function. This is just like a side effect. Right?
So imagine if you do, Oh, wait, I got to run it and then,
okay, so print dog. So what do you think will happen if I do this?
They're going to print and for let's try. Yes it is. Okay, cool.
So basically it returns, you could return stuff.
You can also return mean to return. It means like to imagine, like to,
after you're pressed that function,
it passes on a value so that another function can use it or something else.
Okay. Yeah. So how do you use these things that you pass on?
Good question. You didn't ask me, but good question.
Here's what we call it parameters. Right?
So in your SpongeBob we could add parameters.
So what parameters are our variables kind of, but on functions,
like for example, you could say a parameter, let's just do something easy.
Like hello, just to show you that, you know,
so what happens is let's add hello.
Let's see what happens. Okay. Then SpongeBob.
Now you can add stuff into it. Like let's just add a random number five.
What do you think it's going to print this?
Is it going to add five to the end of hi, my name is Punjab. Yes, that's right.
But you also have to know the operator rate or comparison operators,
which is like, for example, just fine.
So for equals a big distinction,
there's a distinction between like the one equal sign and two equal sign.
One equal sign is when you want to assign something to something to equal sign
is you're comparing like is four equals four. Yeah.
So what do you think will happen if I do [inaudible] who will
return true. Yes. Okay. What if I do five?
What do you think that is? What happened? They'll return false. Yeah. It's like,
what if I do? And uh,
more ways to, what have I do this? What do you think?
That's funny. False. No, it's true. Let's do the math
plus X.
So I asked him to write a simple function that requires if statements and
operators. Let me do some squats.
Binge channel finished shadow.
Hmm. It is negative one. That's good. It's dope. It's dope.
Wow. Good job. Good job.
Let me whispered to my channel. All right guys.
So I'm actually trying to teach him recursion without him knowing
it's recursion. So let's see if he, uh, if he gets it right.
I'd say probably not, but cool. See
such competence booster. You heard that?
[Inaudible].
Joel. I'm done. Yeah.
Check it out,
dude. He can't do that, man. It works up to
yes. Yes. Technically it does work. Yes. But I mean,
what if you don't want to do seven, right? Oops. So yeah.
Yeah. It doesn't even return anything. All right. Okay. It's okay. Um,
it's okay. I didn't expect you to get it because you know,
it's you really had to think outside the box and stuff like that. But uh,
no worries. This is very creative. I actually liked this.
So basically what I want to teach you is recursion.
So it means you could call the function within the function as in,
you're going to call yourself. All right.
So I'm not going to teach you all this because we're actually running out of
time. So we're going to end it here, but I'm just going to show you real quick,
what the code looks like. All right. So if an equals zero,
turn on. And
So basically what I did here is oops,
I did the two initial number for zero one, one. And then Alice,
what do you want to do is you want to add the previous one and the previous,
previous one, right? So all you do is,
and minus one plus and minus two,
and then that's it very simple. All right.
Then if you do flip six, interesting.
I forgot to put return, man,
if you put 56, because you're 13,
seven 21. There you go. There, you have it. All right.
I hope that you enjoyed the small tutorial that would cramp them to 30 minutes,
but, uh, yeah, you did well. I mean, we learned a lot of things in functions,
builder and variables, parameters, and you know, conditions.
So this is pretty good.
Hopefully next time you'll be able to make a web app on your own. Yeah.
Next tutorial. But yeah. So it gives,
you don't know I'm going to maybe start doing some, uh,
Python courses that will, uh,
I don't know how much yet I still have to refine it. And uh, yeah,
I'm really excited because I think finally it's going to be something very,
very useful for you guys. And also it can help me pay him.
Yes.
Because he is quite expensive and I need to start paying this guy to make my
videos for me. All right. Cool. So I'll be like this video, if you like it,
don't forget to like, and subscribe and also press the Belbin for notification.
And also it's Mecho so don't forget to follow his channel
somewhere. Yeah. I don't do that. I don't do that.
I usually just black the screen after. Right. So usually it just goes like.
[Inaudible].